hey guys it's isaiah and this week i'm
going to be on truth to dab
me too
[Music]
you fell
you dropped the ball
hey what's going on everybody for first
week feast i'm shawn evans and welcome
back to another exciting episode of
truth or dab the hot one special where
we give our guests two simple options
tell the truth or suffer the wrath of
the last app and today i'm very excited
to welcome buffalo bills wide receivers
gabriel davis and isaiah mckenzie their
back-to-back afc east champions and part
of a juggernaut offense at buffalo that
reminds bills fans of the early 90s
they're fast they're fun and today they
proudly represent the upstate mecca of
wings in a game of truth or dab gabriel
isaiah welcome to the show yes thanks
for having us and isaiah we'll start
with you the reports that last year as
many as eight teams were vying for your
services but you remain loyal to buffalo
saying money is nice but if we got paid
in candy i'd still stay in buffalo my
question to you is this of the eight
teams that you turned down which was the
easiest and fastest no thank you
[Music]
[Laughter]
i'm sweating
so he asked you which team sucks the
most oh my god yeah i'm getting this way
here
three
here we go
where's eva
okay do it again
i had to finish the wing man
going in
yeah
my eyes dropped
yeah my ex-girlfriend was spanish so we
can do huh
so the spices was a little different
it's a little different
all right gabriel while isaiah endures
that while isaiah endures that i read
that during your time at ucf you're
obsessive about watching game film on
other receivers in your quest to be one
of the best out there i'm curious though
when you look at tape of your teammate
isaiah mckenzie what do you see can you
identify his biggest strength as a
receiver and then what would you say is
his biggest weakness
oh man that's that i can honestly answer
that easy he's his biggest his biggest
strength is his speed
he's a fast guy he hit the corner real
quick just last week he hit 20 miles an
hour
faster fastest one in the game
but then his weakness what he's so
little
you know he's real small guy he gets
tossed around a lot
gets thrown her feet up in the air
everything like that so that's why you
know
right
boy relax but yeah it's definitely his
size his size what the hell am i doing
here
all right isaiah moving on here and a
chance to return the favor how many
miles we get can you give me a wide
receiver skill or maybe even a drill in
practice that your teammate gabriel
cannot touch you in in one-on-one
competition
that's easy but damn it's hard dig the
milk drink the milk oh yeah
that ain't enough what hey i'm so small
i'm gonna go with the latter drill
that brother feet but
this [ __ ] is hot
that's just the first one
right but you know what you just keep
answering it honestly then you're good
to go you're good to go he can't he
can't mess with me in the last drill
like my feet are
way better than his
i'm gonna let him have you over there
struggling but
he's a little smaller man so he got just
strings i got my strength
speaking of strengths gabriel in the
divisional playoff you had that amazing
game 200 yards and obviously the media
very effusive with the praise it's not
always that way though is it with the
media
can you identify a reporter
a talking head a media outlet that you
think covers you and the team most
unfairly
listen i'm letting you know right now
shut up man
i ain't trying to think about it more
ball and i'm losing my hair as we speak
[Music]
going in gabriel joining the party
[Music]
all right the whole thing
you got to you got you oh my god
don't stick your finger in your ear it
didn't this this is this all right cool
i think i got my ear burner
come on finish
you talking about it ain't bad
it is horrible
i'm a live bike where you gotta go yeah
no i'm gonna finish that look at that
i bet like pop my ear
all right i'm ready we're only two more
rounds to go only two more rounds
we got it all right
isaiah
alongside the fridge and megatron your
nickname a little dirty it belongs in
the pantheon of all time great nfl
nicknames who though in your opinion is
actually the dirtiest player in the
league we're not talking about the guys
who refuse to shower after practice
i got hairy [ __ ] in my mouth the
dirtiest player of the league
no i named somebody
my name is
there we go
come on
isaiah about that action
yeah
splitting wings
doing buffalo proud
gabriel while isaiah enjoys that wing
you know bill's mafia the antics they've
been widely talked about and i know from
first-hand experience i've seen it up
close and personal as i often have the
camera guys the bills fans that work on
the show over to my apartment for
playoff watch parties off the top of
your head what's been the most bizarre
or most unforgettable face-to-face
interaction that you've ever had with a
member of bill's mafia
unforgettable
why you sweat no because i'm about to
think i'm about to tell you
i was pulling out of the other facility
and there was a lady out there where one
was working she took her top off
they just danced and just with the whole
top i've got the things showing and all
just out there dancing showing some love
show support and i was like that bill's
my fear right there
you ain't gonna get that nowhere else
she had no care in the world well
speaking of bills mafia we're gonna
close out the show with a very special
guest if you couldn't tell by the pants
a certified member camera guy bill he's
a massive bills fan this is a gift of
football fans but truly this episode is
a gift for camera guy bill so bill i'm
gonna take over the camera bill you take
over the show watch number two getting
hot don't mess it up
why does it get hot
hi guys what's up
uh as a lifelong bills fan and a buffalo
boy born and raised i'm very excited for
you guys to be here this is a dream come
true thanks for the support man uh thank
you for everything you do for the city
and i'm excited to see next season
uh gabriel this final question is for
you well it's pop quiz time
you've been an avid fisherman since
childhood and i read that you've even
tried your hand at fly fishing steelhead
in the rivers of new york since moving
to buffalo yeah so now i'm going to hit
you with some high stakes trivia about
fishing you guys can work together i'll
give you one freebie wrong answer but
every wrong answer after that we all
have to eat a wing wait what
wait shut up
wait
number two is hot as hell
you want to eat number two so we're
gonna you ready for some trivia yeah
come on i got it you guys can work
together you're working together yeah
yeah but if you get it wrong we all we
all have to eat a wing i don't know i
don't know nothing about fish but you
gotta rely on gabriel there you go
i'm sweating i got it come on okay what
you mean
first question yeah what type of fish is
nemo in finding nemo what a mackerel a
clownfish a marlin or a guppy
easy clown right answer yeah one for one
here we go man i'm in the water next
question
true or false
steelhead trout are andromedous meaning
they return to their original hatching
grounds to spawn true true two for two
okay next question wait gay what what
was that he's got it he's go he's two
for two good job
which size hook is the largest one six
or thirty two
wait think about it think that up man
one got it three for three
wow how do you know
because boy i be fishing well i know
about that
last question thank god what is the most
popular freshwater game in the u.s
perch largemouth bass catfish or trout
four for four
wow congratulations wait don't eat that
what are you doing you can if you want
i might as well eat it since you ate it
yeah yeah all right i'll eat one too
let's do it
you know you want either i'll join the
party yeah right no no no jordan party
hit the third one oh
all right i'm on the third one i'm going
to the third one let me see is that
number three it's covered yeah
all right we skipped two to buffalo go
bills go bills go bills baby
yeah you
go bills josh i love you josh alex
oh
oh man
i'm really
[Applause]
the hiccups what we got going